In addition to the numeric data, there are several other benefits and
costs to be aware of. Individual skills can be enhanced by looking at other
people's artifacts. There's some evidence to suggests that lightweight reviews,
those involving the author and a couple of other people doing desk checking,
are more effective in finding defects per staff hour. Of course,
this does not mean that more total defects are detected and when using them,
it is more difficult to collect overall organizational data.
Your organization is going to have to learn from trying out various
approaches as to what's the most effective approach within that organization.
You should also be aware of the so-called ego effect. That is, the knowledge
that an author's artifact will be reviewed tends to improve the quality of
the delivered artifact. That is if you're going to show what you're doing to
somebody else, you're going to make it better. However, there's a danger of
damaged egos when an author is confronted with his or her defects. Collectively,
there is also what is called the big-brother effect, in which stress levels
are raised because people know they are being watched and measured.